Speaker 1: Donald Trump is continuing his
media tour, meanwhile, and he somehow ended
up on the Stuart Varney show on the Fox Business
Channel.
Fox Business is like the lower rated counterpart
to Fox News, Stuart Varney is.
I won't even say much about him.
Stuart Varney is a guy who in this interview
allows Donald Trump to just say whatever the
hell he wants, even obvious lies, and get
away with it with no pushback.
And Stuart Varney, you know, he loves bringing
on Richard Wolffe, economist Richard Wolffe,
friend of our show.
My former Professor Varney will bring on Richard
Wolffe and argue with him.
If if Wolf says the sky is blue, Stuart Varney
is going to argue with him.
And Trump comes in and he talks about ballot
dumps from Matt Mark Zuckerberg.
He talks about how he won the election.
And here is a brilliant idea from Trump during
this interview.
You want to stop cyber attacks, Stewart, stop
using computers.
Hell, Trump has no idea how to use one.
Do we even really need computers?
This is the suggestion of the former president.
Take a look.
Well, that's here to stay, according to the
commerce secretary.
How do we stop it?
Speaker 3: I mean, the conversation
Speaker 4: is more old fashioned form of accounting.
And, you know, I have a son who is so good
with computers, is a young person.
And I mean, he can make these things sing.
And when you put everything on the Internet
and on all of these machines, you never see
a piece of paper.
I really think you have to go back to a different
form of of accounting, a different form of
of compiling information because anybody can
break in.
I mean, I see young people, they they can't
walk without computers that what they can
do with them is incredible with this.
Do it because as a young girl, as a young
person, my 15 year old son is you know, he's
just a genius with this stuff.
And you have you have people that are going
to break into systems.
I think you have to go back and you have to
be much more reliant.
They have to be there has to be much better
security.
And the kind of information that I think is
mind boggling,
Speaker 1: he simply can't avoid mentioning
that Barron knows how to use computers any
time he talks about cyber attacks.
Trump is such a Luddite when it comes to computers
that he's always if computers are mentioned,
you should see what my 15 year old son is
doing with them.
But listen to the suggestion.
How do you deal with cyber threats?
Just get everything off the Internet, stop
using computers.
He sounds like an out of touch old guy who
just refuses to accept modern technology.
It's stunning.
And Stuart Varney just accepts it.
He says, well, that would take some time,
but he's basically accepting it.
How is that a solution anybody can take seriously
even for a second.
Then Trump's move on, moves on.
Trump moves on to pushing the completely baseless
conspiracy theory that U.S. covid cases and
deaths were falsely overcounted to make him
look bad.
We're going back to May of twenty twenty,
my friends.
The truth is the opposite.
Cases and deaths are undercounted.
And we'll talk about that in a moment.
But here is Trump.
Stuart Varney.
Like a doormat.
He offers no pushback whatsoever.
Speaker 4: Things we are in a position a lot
of people that have had covid.
And, you know, I think you had reported numbers
far greater than the actual numbers.
A person that I know just told me his father
died.
I said, oh, that's too bad.
What happened was a heart attack, but they
put down covid.
I said, what do you mean?
It was only did he have covered.
No, he didn't have covered.
They put down covered so many, so many deaths
are reported.
This whole thing is whether it was election
fraud or other frauds.
But, you know, there are many, many more cases
than if you take a look and I'm sure you've
heard this, you're a professional, to put
it mildly.
But this was just an interesting conversation
I had with somebody that I frankly, that I
barely know.
And they said it was covid.
But I've heard that many times before, many,
many times before.
Speaker 1: Is it over in
Speaker 5: America
Speaker 1: now?
So there it is.
Somebody Trump barely knows mentioned this
to him.
This is a how many times has this been debunked?
This goes back to May of twenty twenty.
We are undercounting we are undercounting
covid cases and deaths.
First of all, before testing was ramped up,
there were tons of cases.
My girlfriend and I think.
We may have had this when we were in Europe
very, very early in 2020, there was no testing.
So there are likely hundreds of thousands,
if not millions of cases that were never captured
because there wasn't enough testing at one
point in time.
Then asymptomatic cases.
There were tons of asymptomatic cases which
still could have been transmitting.
People never thought to go and get a test.
There were lots of people who had cold like
or flu like symptoms and just didn't feel
sick enough to even go and get treatment or
seek medical advice.
They were never tested.
The real number of covid cases in the U.S.
is likely two to three times the official
rate.
And then as far as deaths go, there were many
deaths.
We know particularly early on, no autopsies
were done.
There was no Posthumus covid testing.
There were people who died at home who were
never tested.
So the real numbers are much higher than the
official numbers, not lower.
But Varnay doesn't care.
He's going to let Trump say whatever he wants.
And then now here is the really big lie that
Donald Trump won in 2020.
No pushback from Stuart Varney and Trump raises
stuff now about lockboxes with dump's ballot
dump's, that is, Trump's a weird guy, but
he met ballot Dems controlled by Mark Zuckerberg
of Facebook.
I mean, it's all crazy.
Take a look at this hour.
Speaker 4: I got 75 million votes, which is
more than any sitting president ever got.
I won the election, but they cheated.
And by the way, Facebook and Zuckerberg with
a five hundred million dollars worth of phony
lockboxes that he put on, some of them had
ninety six percent Biden votes and 96 percent,
they were like just dumping ballots.
It was a phony deal.
Speaker 1: So that's new to me.
I hadn't heard that before.
Phony Zuckerberg Facebook lockboxes with ballot
dumps inside of them.
It's something else.
And it is it's just out of this world disconnected
from reality.
And Varney just watches it all.
He has nothing to say about it.
At some point, it would be amazing if one
of these Fox hosts or Newsmax or whoever,
if they had the guts to simply say, Mr. President,
sir, you will not stop spreading corrosive
lies.
You incited the January six riots.
You seem desperate to do it again.
Not on my show.
Mr. President.
What would happen if a FOX reporter did that?
They'd probably be fired, but wouldn't it
be worth it?
It would be seen as heroic, not just by much
of the United States, but by most of the world.
It would go Gigha viral instantly.
It would if someone really let Trump have
it during one of these interviews.
Instead, Savani is like a clock on the wall,
just silent.
He's like a doormat.
Trump's walking all over him.
I get it.
Varnay has producers.
He wants his job, he was told.
Do the interview in this way.
OK, I'm not saying that this was exactly the
right moment, and I'm not saying that there
wouldn't have been consequences.
But if someone like Varnay had the guts to
just do it, say, Mr. President, this ends
today, you will stop spreading these corrosive
lies that led to that violent insurrection
you lost.
And you can admit it.
If it were actually live and you know that
it would get out there, that would really
be something else.
I encourage any one of these reporters to
think about it, think about what you're doing
for your legacy by allowing Trump to do what
he did to Stuart Varney versus what you could
actually do if you stand up to him and have
the guts to do it.
Just just a thought.
Just a thought.
Make sure you're subscribed to our new YouTube
channel.
We have a completely separate YouTube channel,
Pakman Live.
You can find it at David Pakman.
Dotcom slash Pakman.
Live clips from the live streams.
If you don't often catch the live streams,
we're taking the best pieces, the best elements
of the live streams and putting them on the
second YouTube channel.
We are heading towards our first 5000 subscribers
and you can find it at David Pakman dot com
slash Pakman live.
And for more on the Varnay interview, make
sure you're following us on Instagram David
Pakman show on all one word on Instagram.
We'll take a quick break.
I will be speaking with Professor Oliver Sabuni
coming up next.
A very interesting conversation, I'm sure,
and then much more after that.